[Music]
in an age of streaming
there are personalities that seem to be
born for it
blood wake hey what's up guys
there are players with the skills to
destroy everyone else on the server
and look good while doing it
and then there's disguise toast you guys
imagine
if donuts were on our ears
like oh holiday toast is one of
streaming's biggest stars
but his path to stardom has been as
awkward and
endearing as the man himself hey google
play highway to hell highway to hell by
tdc
sure play on spotify
he realizes it's all ogre now
oh my god
[Laughter]
he may have started his career in
hearthstone but toast has become much
bigger than any one game
he's one of the most beloved streamers
out there and this
is his story
i'm so sorry scissors i'm so sorry
sometimes
best face his own face
[Music]
before he was known as disguised toast
jeremy wang was born in taipei taiwan
his family moved to penang malaysia
within the year and at age 12 his family
immigrated to ontario canada
and even though toast already spoke
english when he arrived
there were still some growing pains like
if i make a mistake
writing with my pencil and like hey can
i borrow some rubber
someone will give me their rubber but
when i came to north america
and i said hey you got rubber people
think i'm talking about condoms
yeah like slip on that rubber in high
school he took up magic tricks as a way
to be
more personable but he quickly realized
he'd like the attention
i eventually became known as the guy who
does
magic in my high school and people were
asked to see magic tricks
when they see me and it was essentially
it gave me
the taste for uh performance
he also programmed a flash game called
the frustration game that was posted on
newgrounds
the idea was simple keep your mouse
cursor inside the safe area
but toast's creation actually took off
and someone bought the rights to
advertise in the game and hosted on
their website for a thousand dollars
and there were big youtubers who found
the game and played it
and the fact that they were creating
content based on his game was an
eye-opening experience for him oh my god
we've got i think we're gonna have to
play a different game because this game
is just stupid
it doesn't work it doesn't work
it doesn't work it's just broken but as
he graduated and pondered his work
options
blizzard announced their warcraft theme
card game hearthstone
and the game took off not only was it
incredibly popular with fans but
it also blew up on twitch where
thousands of viewers tuned in to watch
an emerging generation of streamers play
the game non-stop
and toast was addicted too he watched
the streamers experiment with different
deck types and then started making his
own hearthstone content
so instead of following the career paths
that his education pointed him towards
he continued to produce content about
the game and eventually
chose the name disguise toast a play on
the intro line spoken by the si7
agent card this guy's toast
then in the summer of 2015 toast took
his content into the real world for the
first time
he went to a tournament in toronto but
since no one knew what he actually
looked like
toast had to come up with a creative
solution but no one really knew who i
was
i never spoke in any of my videos nor
did i make any appearances
and since my logo was infinitely more
recognizable than me
i decided to make a cardboard cutout of
it
and use that to take a picture with [ __ ]
but after he was convinced to wear the
mask on stream and combined with his
weird personality and off meta play
toast became somewhat of a celebrity in
the scene yeah i can't wait to hear the
finals tonight when or the finals on
sunday at least when those guys are
banging those thunder six it is going to
be
like 500 decibels in here oh no
he realizes it's all ogre now
oh my god oh my god
[Laughter]
there's a brilliant video there's a
channel called disguised toast
which is a it's a it's a play on that
the whole yeah this guy's toast thing
when you play the sr7 agent
he went to a tournament in a toast mask
with a pair of uh sunglasses he won the
whole
thing but like and he did this montage
he's on camera all the time
and he's doing expressive stuff like he
pulls off this movie he does the john
cena you can't see me thing
and he's just this kind of toast mask
and crippery is making a bunch of jokes
about it it's the best
thing in the universe hearthstone was
twitch's latest obsession and disguised
toast as he was now known
was popping off
toast began streaming on twitch but
unlike pretty much every other big
streamer
he didn't show his face until eventually
the illusion
was shattered oh my god
oh my god oh my god you guys just saw my
face
ah no
while many of his fans tried to keep the
secret a determined viewer posted the
clip
everywhere including the live stream
fails subreddit where the clip got
too many views to ignore the internet
finally saw the man beneath the mask
but rather than hurt him toast
popularity
and stream only grew sometimes
best space own face
and toast continued to expand his
content too he focused on strange
decks bizarre card interactions and
hitting legend the game's highest rank
with a free-to-play deck
a real challenge in the notoriously
pricey hearthstone meta
yes
yes oh my god i didn't think it was
possible
free to play hunter yes yes yes yes yes
yes
in early 2017 he even dipped his toes
into competitive play as he entered a
hearthstone
major at pax east he's picking it up
he's feeling it out
he's the carrot it's dangerous
oh my god oh my god
look at that toast with this banana grin
but on day two of that tournament toast
slipped in
so long that he got disqualified but
isn't just sleeping in bed much better
have you ever just
wanted like you know you have to go to
school or go to work
and you're like five minutes five
minutes bro five minutes
the disappointing end to his tournament
didn't hurt his popularity though
toast was invited to the bahamas as an
influencer for the hct winter
championship in 2017 where he streamed
constantly
but later that year toast's hearthstone
career started to break down
he showcased an exploit on his stream
that completely crashed the game which
blizzard was
not happy about right
oh my god it's a monster
half mirage collar half reluctant
blizzard didn't like that toast was
popularizing a game-breaking exploit and
slapped him with a short band from a
hearthstone
i understand their concern by doing a
youtube video on an exploit
thousands of people will see it and
abuse it for themselves
which in turn will ruin a lot of games
for innocent people
although toast didn't immediately stop
playing hearthstone there was no
question that his relationship with
blizzard had soured
the whole ignoring all my messages and
ghosting me
kind of stuff making me think that
you know i was flying to california
without even a courtesy oh sorry it's
not happening
that made my relationship with blizzard
terrible absolutely terrible but
maybe toast could see the writing on the
wall he had grown immensely because of
hearthstone but the game was no longer
dominating twitch as it once had
it was time for toast to strike out on
his own and once again
do something completely different so
when he announced in the fall of 2017
that he would be joining the offline tv
content house
it seemed like a natural fit all right
guys i'm proud to announce our newest
offline tv house member
this guy's toast no one else we could
have used
no literally was [ __ ] not available
isn't he uh
like a hearthstone streamer wait what's
hard stuff wait isn't it that cheap
yu-yo knock-off like
it's like it's another asian guy i
already have so many asian people
this is really ridiculous
and because of his entertaining
personality it didn't take too long for
toast to become an important piece of
the offline tv content team alongside
huge names like pokeman lily pichu and
scara
oh he's just really nice that's the kind
of thing you say when you don't have
anything actual
you guys imagine the donors were on our
ears
like oh holiday like once like
you're kind of attracted but he's like
oh my god oh do you have anyone to hold
the camera for you while you go to the
bathroom for my plan is to just not go
to the bathroom today
or if i want a vacation you know i've
been feeling a little burnt out if i
want a vacation i can just film the
bathroom right
wait so this is how i take seven days
off
without looking like i'm lazy where's
the bathroom
i toast because give me a serious answer
about me man
okay all right toast is a really nice
guy
toast became part of the upper crust of
gaming content and his success gave him
another opportunity
in november of 2019 amid the rush for
streaming platforms to lock down big
names
he quickly inked a deal with facebook
gaming
but once again toast bucked expectations
instead of making some crazy
announcement video toast took the
production budget and put it towards a
much more meaningful cause
we had 20k production budget
and i took that check drove down to the
children hospital of los angeles
and gave it to them because honestly you
guys don't really
care how it's announced you guys just
care where i'm moving to so
i'm moving to facebook gaming check me
out there bye
as toast left hearthstone behind and
experimented with other games
he quickly found himself at the
forefront of yet another streaming craze
among us oh my god
what did you know ninja you didn't know
[ __ ] you don't know [ __ ]
where's your left nut send it over to me
as the game exploded in popularity
toast's own weird brand of humor blended
perfectly with the game's high intrigue
antics
there's been two sets of double kills so
hard man
right if he did then i he deserves it
yeah
and his high profile in the games
community led to another huge chance
he played among us alongside us
congresswoman alexandria ocasio-cortez
and iohan omar
in one of the biggest twitch events of
the year oh no
no no the other imposter okay do it
do it
crack snack all right
so aoc has found the body
since then toast has continued to focus
on among us and his iq
has steadily climbed becoming perhaps
the most intelligent human being alive
if his youtube titles are accurate and
since facebook gaming really is
specifically focused on video games he's
even been able to show up on his own
twitch channel
now and again did santa give you what
you wanted this year what do you want
for christmas twist
ah i mean it's too late anyone who's
gonna give me a gift has given me a gift
wait
santa's real what did you watch
did you check under the christmas tree
today
no not yet
don't you worry tell us i'm sure santa
got you what you wanted
to go from a three-year math degree to
one of the most popular streamers on the
planet is
one hell of a ride and toast did it his
way
with his signature sense of humor
penchant for the weird
and briefly a mask that looked like a
piece of toast
anyone want to buy my underwear 50 bucks
per pair up on these 100
if you want me to fart in it beforehand
oh 1000 bits from spikes
you get underwear
[Music]
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this
hit the sub button and ring that
notification bell for unique bite size
videos you won't find anywhere else
hit up our instagram twitter and
facebook pages